I don't want to give too much of an
introduction because I think we had an
excellent keynote and the speaker
explained very well why we need to be
careful when we use machine learning
system in everyday life and I mean just
to be brief here I want to Google a new
search and so I try to see what is
currently in the news when it comes to
when you answer like machine learning
and fairness and as you can see in the
United States they're already like many
approaches where people try to use
machine learning systems to automate
decisions that have been previously been
made by humans and that's different
motivations for that mostly it's about
course but also about efficiency and
maybe some other metrics that you design
until you say ok well yes they can do
whatever they want then I probably in
Germany we're more we might be more
careful about it but then oh actually
yeah also here like these systems
especially for example here predictive
policing are being used more and more to
replace processes that were before
carried out manually so that means that
it's more important than ever today to
think about what it actually means if we
use machine learning and data analysis
to automate these kind of processes and
so what is fairness
fairness is in principle not a technical
concept so people are being fair or
unfair to other people so it's nothing
that falls directly in the real nor the
machine learning but if we use machine
learning to automate processes that were
carried out by humans we can make it a
technological problem because the biases
or the unfairness that isn't the normal
process can be automated or repeated
using the technology so a machine
learning systems again I want to say is
important that they are Pursey not fair
or unfair but it has the potential to be
either one of them depending on how we
actually make use of them so and
personally I think it's not always a bad
thing to use machine learning or
automated processes where we have been
making decisions for humans before
because I think if we use these systems
correctly we have a large chance of
actually eliminate
many of the biases in many of the
problems that we are inherent in them
and so we just need to make sure that we
use them in a good in a right way and a
careful where as well so when people
talk about fairness they mostly think
about discrimination and discrimination
is actually a treatment of the certain
group of people that can be
characterized by an attribute such as
for example the identity the gender or
sexual orientation in a way that is
preferential or discriminatory in
comparison to another group and again
they're like many areas in our life
where discrimination happens some of
them are maybe less severe for the
person being discriminated for example
is I'm online and I'm trying to book a
flight and my flight search engine shows
me only like a very expensive price
because it sees I'm on an ipod and
things are maybe a user with a bit more
money then this might be nuisance for me
but it's not something that would like
threaten my freedom or like have a very
large impact on my life but as there are
more and more processes that we automate
with machine learning such as credit
ranking the decision who to hire or who
to invite to like a recruiting interview
or even who to put on parole which was
like heat in jail or who to control or
not as a policeman these kind of
decisions that are made by these
automated systems tend to have a bigger
and bigger effect on our lives and if we
want to think about discrimination in in
context of machine learning you of
course has to have a mathematical
definition because we cannot measure
anything that we don't know how to
define and there are different ways to
do this so here I'm sure one of the ways
which has been established in 40 years
ago already in which is in wide use
which is why I'm also have it here as a
first example and it's so called
and it's based on the probability of
making it through a process as the
member of a given group so here you with
a like a diagram you can see they're two
groups of people which are called X
equal zero and X equal one and they're
going through process which at the end
has either positive outcome or negative
outcome and now we can ask ourself
is there a dependent on the group
membership of a given person on the
success probability or the probability
that he or she will make it through this
process and if we look at this we can
like make the quotient between these two
probabilities so the probability that
the answer is yet and that the person is
not a member of this group egg and
divided by the probability that the
answer is yes divided given that the
person is enrolled in school that's what
we call the so-called disparate impact
or towel here and this definition of
discrimination has been used in like
various contexts for example in the u.s.
if you have the process that at the
towel value which is larger as a smaller
than 0.8 so 80% and this would get you
into legal trouble and again this
measure is not perfect it's very simple
and the way it's formulated but it
actually allows us to see a lot of cases
of discrimination in our system and the
important thing here to notice is that
this only makes sense if you assume that
the people which are eating the first on
the second group are similarly all other
metrics that are relevant so if there
are any differences between the people
this way of looking at discrimination
would not be justified so to say an
advantage of that scheme here is that
it's very easy to actually implement or
measure and practice so the only thing
that you need to do if you have a
process where you send people through is
to measure how many of them make it
through from the first group how many
don't make it through from the first
group and the same things on the second
group and then you make like this
numerical quotient of these four numbers
and this gives you an estimate of the
cella factor so it's a really easy and
very powerful way of measuring or seeing
if there's any discrimination in the
process that we are designing as I said
it's not a perfect measure there are
alternatives so the disparate impact is
the so called group based measurement so
it only looks at different groups and
respect to each other and so it wouldn't
be able to see some forms of
discrimination for example I could
imagine like still like having territory
between the two groups
only choosing like the worst people for
members of one group that make it
through the process thereby
discriminating people that for example
has better attributes in this protected
group so I can still do some
discrimination that wouldn't be seen by
this kind of measure and other measures
which are which do not have this folder
so-called individual based and
discrimination of fairness measures so
there the idea is shown here what you
need for that is to define a distance
function that would give you a distance
between two of it
your individuals in the data set based
on the characteristics or attributes
that you deem acceptable for comparing
individuals so it should of course not
include any of the attributes which you
do not want to discriminate people by
and then you can take this distance and
compare it to another distance function
that gives it a distance between the
actual treatment that these people are
undergoing qutuz in the system and you
can normally find if your system is not
discriminating you will be able to find
a constant that is such that people
which are indeed which are similar would
also be treated similarly and this
definition makes it easier to find
discrimination which cannot be captured
by the group based approach I will not
talk about this in this talk because
it's a quite sophisticated concept and
the problem is of course that you need
to find a corresponding or good distance
function which is not always easy
therefore I will continue with the
normal disparate impact based
discrimination measure I just wanted to
be sure to say that there are other
approaches to measuring discrimination
in this kind of processes so instead of
continuing with the theories I want to
now go with you through the process of
actually designing a system that
automates something that has been done
manually and it also has a large impact
on the lives of people and you know that
I showed some news article about
predictive policing and so there are
lots of projects in this area throughout
the world and the goal is usually to
kind of under echt the the efforts of
police officers so that they have a
higher likelihood of finding criminals
for example and they are for example
programs for this in New York but also
in Germany and we could ask ourselves
the question can we design an algorithm
that would help a police officer - for
example negative Asian if he should or
she should like control or frisk someone
so like pat-down summon and see if the
person is maybe hiding something and of
course in order to do that we would need
to do like some really large-scale
social experimentation on people first
to get all the data and it sounds like a
crazy idea to do of course but
fortunately somebody or they already did
that work for us because in New York
they had this so-called stop and frisk
program which was a program running
between 2004 and about like 2014 which
basically gave the right to a police
officer to just jobs stop someone in the
street and then perform a search on that
person so and the reason for that stop
could be very vague for the product the
police officer basic aid a lot of leeway
of determining which people to stop and
which to frisk them and you can see them
many hundreds of thousands of people
that have seen in millions of people
that has been frisk in this time frame
from 2003 to 2014 and yeah every time
this happens the police officers what
was required to make a report about it
so there's a lot of paperwork with a
very detailed analysis of each case that
we can use to train an algorithm again
so here actually all the input variables
that we have available in this data set
you can see I tried to group them
roughly by on things that are related to
the appearance of a given person things
that are related to the behavior of the
person and things that are related to
the circumstances so you can see in the
appearance volume you have such things
which for example the age of the suspect
the ways I don't know if they have a
scale there where they measure people
but somehow they determined it the
height of the the person in feed so five
six or seven
for example the eye color the raise to
take the bills and other attributes and
you also have like behavior based
information for example if that person
reacted evasively to questioning
whatever that might mean if the subject
seemed to be acting a lookout for
example or if the subject change the
direction when seeing a police officer
and finally you have other attributes
which are related needed not to the
behavior or not to the appearance but to
the circumstances what I call and they
are such things is if the frisking was
made inside or outside the building if
it was made into in a metro station and
at which time of the day it was made in
which precinct so this corresponds
roughly to like a block or a
neighborhood in New York and some other
things and of course it's really
difficult to say what kind of like
interpretation lies below the beneath
the data and for example if a seed is
like wearing clothes commonly used in a
crime I I don't know what exactly
defines it so but let's assume that
these things are all like objective-c or
mostly objectively taken and that we can
use them as a basis for our algorithm so
that leaves us with like forty different
attributes almost that we can use and we
have in the data set also three
attributes that we can use for training
the first one is the fact if the person
described T has been frist so it has
been has been searched and the second
one is the person has been arrested
subsequently and the third one is if
that person has been summoned to come to
a police station as to
so this would be our training our target
data so to say now in order to make an
algorithm for this we need to have a
process model first and this model is
shown here so you would have all the
people that are in a database and then
we have a choice we can either choose to
frisk that person or not risk that
person and if we do that then afterwards
it might be some evidence that leads to
an arrest of a given person or not to an
arrest so in the next slide what I would
be calling a true positive is so to say
the case when you have a person that we
frisk and if we also arrest because
there's maybe some evidence where is the
false positive is the person that the
first but we do not arrest the person is
innocent so to say and correspondingly
there's here the true negatives so
people we don't risk and we don't arrest
and there's also here the false negative
which is like we don't risk a person but
these are now arrested which is I don't
know even how that works in the data but
it's also case that we have to take care
of so now we want to build a system that
decides when actually whether to risk
someone or not and doing that we want to
try to maximize the discovery of
criminal people while not ideally
bordering the law-abiding citizens and
of course we also do not want to
discriminate against certain groups of
people in order to do that we first need
to choose an America loss function that
we can train our algorithm again and
here again we have to make a choice
so as we will see later most of the
people that in the data set actually
didn't commit any kind of crime or any
have any reason to be arrested so this
means that our system will have a lot of
false positives probably because if
people will get risk that don't have and
on anything wrong and we need to take to
balance that against the the probability
of not frisking someone who I all might
be a criminal so
can do that by using a so-called weight
parameter in our system which would tell
the algorithm okay if you frisk someone
who is not we didn't commit a crime
you will get a penalty of minus one but
if you frisk someone who is then
arrested you will get a reward which is
equal to alpha and it's not exact but
you can actually reformulate it as this
so it would basically say to the
algorithm it's okay to frisk alpha plus
1 people if you find one criminal then
because then your score is going up
these are 3 6 10 people and assigned 11
people and I find one criminal with an
alpha of 10 then the score would stay
the same so in a sense we're going here
from a state where like police is very
polite and not checking anyone to like a
total surveillance state where everybody
is under suspicion and your life is
basically an endless t is a security
line now before we start designing the
algorithm or training it we want to have
a look at how actually the data is like
and if there is any discrimination
inside the training data that we use and
as I thought as we saw before the people
here and as a so-called race attribute
which is the term that I don't like at
all by the way that gives the race or
the ethnicity of the people in the data
set you can see we have for example
black people or white people this is a
thing like Latin American white Latin
American other or unknown and Asian
people and for each of these groups of
people we have the first probability or
the the the frequency of them being
faced in this data set you can see for
black people
for example 50% of the people that were
stopped will also freeze whereas for
white people only 35% of the people that
were stuffed up were actually fit and
you can see already there there might be
some bias going on and of course it
could outdated on maybe these people in
one group
stop we're acting like suspiciously so
there was a good reason to stop them and
in fact you can answer that question by
looking at the second row here which
gives the probability of an arrest being
made after the first thing happens you
know and you can see that for example
for black people in 80% of the cases no
arrest is made
whereas for white people in 73 percent
of the cases so that means more of these
white people here get arrested than of
the black people which would indicate
that there is over the lights and then
tendency to frisk more black people
image might not be justified so there
seems to be some discrimination going on
here already and again this is open to
interpretation but it always depends on
how you measure similarity and fairness
in the system but for media certainly
some discrimination in this data okay so
now nevertheless let's used it in order
to build a model and so what we do here
um is a multi-step protest
so we first take our input data I used
only the data from the year 2003 for
that um I selected the different
attribute and those are mostly like
either like yes/no or binary attributes
like what is inside or outside or in an
MTA station or not but some of these
attributes they were also continuous or
categorical like the race for example
ethnicity or the time of the day and for
these attributes what we did was so
called one hot - method where we define
a category for each possible values of
these we define sorry an attribute for
each possible values of a given category
a categorical attribute so if you have
for example ten ethnicities we would
define ten new attributes which are
called black white asian wide etcetera
and would give that attribute of one if
the person is number of that group and a
zero if not so having done that we get
about like 170 categorical or yes/no
attributes that we can use for the
training we can then just train a simple
classifier in our case I choose a
logistic regression from scikit-learn
which is easy and
it's like works quite well on this kind
of kind of data we dented the data set
into a training and a test set in this
case we did that with a 70/30 split so
70% of the data was used for training
fully present and for testing and we
will generate various models for a range
of these outer values and seeing how the
algorithm behaves now the first thing
that we want to do is to see if we can
predict if a given person was first in
the data set given all the input
attributes that we have now what I will
show you and in acts makes the 15
minutes would be a lot of discharge so I
wanted to take a moment to explain
exactly what they show and how to
interpret them so what you have here is
on one hand the false positives in by
the algorithm and the false negatives as
a function of this weights parameter
alpha so we start with a weight of 0
here basically that would tell the
algorithm only our first people where
you're 100% sure that they might get
arrested to a value of about 15 where
the algorithm would be able to frisk 15
people if it finds at least one criminal
so to say and I'm here plot the this
line shows the total number of people in
the dataset about $40,000 is slightly
less than 40,000 and this other line
shows the number of people that has been
fished so and as you can see I hope you
can see it there's a blue line which
represents the choice of the algorithm
and there's a green line which we use
for comparison and the green line
basically chooses the same number of
people as the algorithm but the truth is
them totally randomly and this is the
benchmark that we use to test our
algorithms against because if we want to
build a system we should be sure that it
is at least as good as a totally random
pic of people you know because if we are
not even as good as that we couldn't
have any justification for using this
algorithm we could just like roll the
dice so to say and you can see in this
example which I'll show the algorithm is
slightly better than
taking people at random so we can see
that the difference between the green
and the blue curve for the false
negatives which means that we are
identifying some people that are being
like first in the dataset using the
attribute but there's also some room
here between the green line and the blue
line which means that the algorithm has
categorized some people as being frisked
first who and not getting frisked in the
data set and this can be explained by
the fact that the algorithm will at each
point here in the graph choose the
parameters which have a probability of
increasing like the number of risk
people more scared by the weight factor
more than it increases the number of
false positives so for example if offers
tree then the algorithm could like try
to increase the number of first people
it find by generating about like three
are false positives so it will in that
case so to say trade the false positives
for the true negatives and the dilemma
of our algorithm of designing the system
then comes basically to the point of
choosing an s-parameter that is good and
then seeing what that has which kind of
effect it has on our system for the
first case just as the benchmark is a
simulation where we only give a random
noise to the algorithm so we don't
provide provide any good information and
we see what happens and as you can see
as the algorithm doesn't have any clue
who to pick so it can just pick people
randomly what if we do is that at the
beginning where the false positives have
a very high energy compared to the true
positives it will just you mark everyone
as innocent because we'd say I don't
have any chance of like marking finding
the right people with the good
probabilities will just not risk anyone
but as we increase the as a factor at
some point so in this case about like
other value slightly more than one the
algorithms and say okay now given the
score
or the Alpha value if I frisk everyone
my score would still be higher than if I
first know one because the people that
are being first in this case like 50%
will generate more score than the
penalty I get for the other one so you
can see at this point it completely
switches its strategy and suddenly
everyone is a suspect okay so this is
just to give you an idea of how changing
the Alpha value can change the behavior
and the results of the algorithm in this
context now let's finally give some real
data to the algorithm and see what it
can do with it so now what we're doing
is and to provide all the input
attributes that we have that we
discussed before to the algorithm and
ask it to to predict the frisk value and
you can see it's actually working quite
well because we have a lot of space here
a lot of signal between these two curves
which means that the algorithm is much
better at picking people than just
random children so to say what we also
have bill is the large number of false
positives and you can ask yourself why
is that I mean we explain the reason
before but of course the more
interesting question is what is the
effect on like people from different
groups
is there any bias now in the system
because we saw that there are some
buyers in the input data the question is
can the algorithm actually pick that up
or will it pick it up so in order to
quantify that we now plot here again as
a function of the weight parameter alpha
the percentage of the people first that
will be increased in each ethnic group
so again we have like white people black
people Asian people Latinos and others
and we plot the percentage of people in
a given group that has been chosen for
frisking by our algorithm and as you can
see unfortunately here there is like a
large discrimination going on because
the probability of being frisked if you
and this group here's of your white
person it's much lower then for example
if you
a group of black people so what this
means is that effectively our algorithm
has picked up this bias that is in the
input signal and we produced it in order
to make a better prediction because by
using this bias approach it can increase
the score that we gave it gave to it by
discriminating against these people so
where does the size actually come from
you know and we can answer that question
by trying to like change your algorithm
a little bit so now instead of trying to
predict if a person is getting frisked
or not we will try to predict if that
person belongs to the black group so
given all the other input attribute if
you do that we've not mimicked again the
same plot as before so now only we plot
not the percentage of people being
frisked but instead the percentage of
people categorize this click and as you
can see here for most of the weight
parameters alpha there's a large
difference that the algorithm can pick
up between white people and black people
so for example at the value of two about
90% of all the people in the temple
categorized as black whereas the ground
proof is only 50% if you would choose
people at randomly at random so that
means that there is some information
that the algorithm can use to actually
get predict the ethnicity attribute of a
given person and this in turn is the
basis for which the algorithm can then
discriminate against these people
so now we've seen that it exists so the
question is how can we eliminate it
again there are different approaches
here one approach would be of course to
identify the attributes that are
problematic in a sense that they can
predict the protected attribute as the
ethnicity and then remove these
attributes from the data set and this is
something that we could do with like the
information that we generated in the
last step and it's usually a good idea
if you can clearly identify some
problematic attributes the problem with
that is of course that usually the
attributes that we remove do not only
contain information about the protected
class but they contain some other useful
information about our prediction problem
so by removing them we're also
decreasing the fidelity or the accuracy
of our algorithm the second possibility
is not to remove attributes but instead
to remove a whole data point so if you
can somehow identify which data points
which individuals might have been
subject to discrimination in the data
set we could then just remove those data
points and do not give the algorithm
reason to believe that our reason to
like discriminate against these people
because the discrimination is
effectively or like to a large part
removed from the data set and this is
this is also doable but the problem is
then again that we might also use use
other useful information that we can use
to improve the accuracy of the algorithm
get the variation of that approach with
which consists in not removing the whole
data point for modifying some properties
with that for example you could like add
statistical noise to give an attribute
of a person to make it less less
correlated with a sensitive or protected
attribute again here the problem would
be that we also not only like erasing
this correlation between the protected
attribute and the abnormal attribute
would also other useful correlations
that are in the data so again this is
also not like a perfect way of doing it
the third way would be to not change the
input data but instead put a constraint
on our algorithm so we could for example
give it an additional loss function that
is proportional to the amount of
discrimination that it produced
and then ask it to optimize the combined
loss function of our accuracy and
discrete discrimination measure and
basically what we would tell your ISM
would be to - like restrict the
parameter space to some areas which
contain the allowed solution and then
some space where there they are the
so-called forbidden solution again this
is not a perfect method because it only
provides to say like the minimum viable
our solution to the problem but it's not
guaranteed to deliver the best solution
with no bias at all so it will only do
normally the minimum that is required in
order to meet the criteria and then stop
there so it's not really good approach
if you really want to get rid of
discrimination in your algorithm and of
course the final thing that we could do
is to simply change the target attribute
and to see if we can find something that
might be more suitable and contains less
bias now let's try the first method so
what we do again here is take the
different attribute values and then try
to predict whether a person is a member
of this black group so we do this for
the behavior based attributes and for
the circumstance based attribute and as
you can see here the behavior based
attributes have a much harder time
predicting actually the group membership
than the circumstance based ones and
explanation that I have so this is that
behavior is of course less correlated to
like appearance whereas the circumstance
also contains for example two precincts
so the location where the person was
frisked and as you has different
communities in New York and in some
communities you have like more black
people than others it's of course useful
information is can be picked up by the
algorithm to again give a probability
estimate of how many of the people here
in this area might belong to this given
group so and now we could like based on
this information for example say okay
the behavior based information seems to
be seems to not have a very large bias
in this stance so let's try to use that
one and that's what we do here so
instead of using all the input features
as before we just use the behavior based
one and we again have a look at the
false positives and the false negatives
you can see the blood looks like a lot
more bumpier now and the reason for that
is that there are a lot less features in
there so before we had like 120 features
now we have only maybe 10 features and
you can think of it like that every
feature has a certain probability by
which it can like predict a membership
of this first group inaudible person so
as we move this other parameter at first
the algorithm can only use the features
that are the most predictive and as this
parameter increases and the penalty for
false positive speak for positive
decreases the algorithm can then
sequentially use also attributes which
are less predictive but which can like
produce a little to say increase in the
true positives and you can see that
there still some signal between the two
curves much less signal and before of
course as you can see here and gets also
like in some areas at least less false
positives let's see what this does to on
the disparate treatment between the
individual groups here again has the
same chart so the number of people in
the fridge group grouped by their
ethnicity as a function of the weight
parameter and as you can see now if you
compare this compare this to our earlier
results you can see that there's still
some discrimination going on but it's
less pronounced than before so this
means by removing these problematic
input attributes we were able to reduce
the discrimination I'm done by our
algorithm
but because it's good of course but
still not perfect so let's try the other
strategy that we discussed and that is
changing the target attribute so instead
of arm now using the wrist value so the
person has been frisked or not we will
use instead the fact if the person has
been arrested because the reasoning here
is that it might it's always possible to
frisk someone and if you want that as a
police officer but it's harder to arrest
someone if that person doesn't didn't
commit any crime or is innocent so to
say so what we would expect is that
there is less bias and this target
attribute and in the other target
attribute before okay let's try it
so here's again the result of that you
can see we still have some signal here
so the algorithm is still able to pick
out the people better than random
chooser and at the same time we also
reduced the number of false positives
and the reason for this is that now as
we have many many less people in the
target group so only I think 10% or 20%
of the people that are in the database
were arrested
whereas 50% of them were frisked so it
doesn't make as much sense to trade the
false positives to the fault for the
true net true positives for the
algorithm so to say so it's harder to
actually just like fit more people in
them like get away with that by also
finding some people that might get
arrested because they are not so many
people that are being arrested in the
data set and so the algorithm here has
to be a bit more careful or it cannot
like trade as much as before
okay looking at the bias and this
resulting data we can see that now we
have a much better result than before
because you can see that there's for
example no discrimination against black
people which have infect in the lowest
probability of being frisked but they
are still for example for this group you
some residual discrimination going on
though all the other groups are seen to
be like very close to each other in
terms of the discrimination metric so on
this solution by using which uses both
different target attribute and let's
input attributes than before is much
better than our original Big Data
solutions
David we just like give everything that
we have to the algorithm and try to make
a prediction with it so as a result you
can see here the better but still
imperfect treatment of people by the
algorithm so this is the result of our
method if you choose sorry if you just
put ourselves at the value of seven here
so we make this choice say okay we want
to be at this point and like ever fought
like a frisking probability which is
comparable to the original data and like
get as many of these criminals as
possible and then we see the results
here again as this flowchart and you can
see now that concerning the arrests that
are being made in each group there's
much less difference as compared to
before so here the probability is most
is about 80% which means that at least
on this group measurement approach there
is no large discrimination between
individual groups there is still some
discrimination as you can see here for
this one group of like like Latin
Americans which are getting frisked
significantly more than the other ones
so this is something that we would also
need to take care of if we would design
a real system here okay two takeaways
from that well we can say that as we saw
like most of the training data that we
use in real world algorithms will
contain biases and some of these biases
will be implicit and also not easy to
recognize so if you want to see them we
really have to look and we have to in
use like this correct measures and it's
correct methods to identify them and in
order to protect the people from the
discrimination we need to do something
which is a bit paradoxical because we
actually need to like record all this
all their sensitive data
you know because today most of the
people that are designing data on like
these a great mixed systems they say ok
we couldn't discriminate against people
because we do not even record these
sensitive or protected attributes and
this is the wrong approach because if
you don't record them or if you don't
have them you can never measure if there
is any discrimination in your system so
in order to do that you really need to
have to stay
and finally as I hope I could show
there's also not only a chance of like
making things words using algorithms but
also like a huge chance of making things
actually better as we've seen if you
like our careful and how to design a
process on algorithm we can actually
produce a result which is less bias bias
than the original one even when using
originally bias input data for that now
the final point I'm sorry
we running out of time okay I'm done
right here at 1:00 a.m. and thank you
very much for this really interesting
talk okay maybe not and given the delay
of the talk I'm going to take two
questions and please please be brief I'm
sure you're going to be around so if you
have more questions you could just
approach master words hi um I was
wondering so what's what's in like what
do you would advise the police to do
then I mean to how do you translate your
findings into the real world the
findings here so as a solid like
different ways to deal with these
problems what do you have to do is of
course be sure that you choose the input
data where and that you like tested for
biases and discrimination and then you
need to like actually those are my last
slide which I was not able to show what
I imagined a machine learning system to
be is to have in order to be safe um
it's actually a way to get this
protected data in order to like sanitize
the input data and then also have a way
to audit your algorithm or the outcomes
of the algorithm using fairness metrics
like the one we discussed in the talk
well I mean they're different vendors of
these systems and what I think is
important what is not like done today is
that the algorithms and the target
attributes that are the data are trained
for are not public so in order to have a
system where you would actually have
some way to like see if there's
discrimination you need the data to be
like it is partially open and you need
the algorithm to be open does that
answer the question
No
I sew a quite a quick question so one of
the one of the questions around when we
detect discrimination let's say as in
the Google paper between the orange
population in the blue population their
approach at the end was okay let's
create a model that works as well as you
can and then set different thresholds
for the two populations that is
computationally very elegant politically
very difficult because you know you
would effectively be creating a system
that actively discriminated positively
again with one population in order to
compensate a further bias in the data if
you comment on how you actually design
systems that solve the problem just
rather than just the identification part
so I'm a big fan of an individual based
measures of fairness so um they of
course the problem as I explained is
that you need to find a measure that
like includes the right attributes in
order to compare to people and then it
could be a rest of it would sort of say
be automatically known and you could
just design an algorithm that optimizes
the target value by also are following
this condition that it has like not that
similar people are treated similarly but
I think there's not a universal answer
to that question in some cases you also
can you want maybe to do some
affirmative algorithmic actually know in
order to like even like treat people in
a certain group better or like give them
a bonus so to say in order to like
reduce the discrimination that they are
subjected to so and depending on what
you want to do you need to like define
your target function and you input
attributes in different ways so I think
there's not like a universal approach to
fairness where you can just put in your
data and then you get like a fair result
out so you always have to think about
like what fear is what output attributes
you have and what metrics you want to
use to measure that okay perfect thank
you very much Andrea and so we have five
minutes left